let me ask you first they told me that
you admitted that this was kind of the
most intimidating um you know process
more than anything you've ever
experienced why how come this is late
90s this is um you know me as a
teenager watching this movie and
watching it change pop culture and then
cut two as an actor i'm in it you know
it's kind of
really really cool to
be part of this legacy and be invited to
play on this playground with these
characters that we grew up on you know
and um so i think what was intimidating
also about it was not just that but um
my first shot in the movie was
all the dialogue that i have in the
entire movie
in one sunset
in front of the entire cast so yes that
was very
intimidating i was like oh man i can
feel it here when you say it like that
i'm like oh my gosh my heart starts
beating a little faster for you um but
we got through it you know it was fine
[Music]
on such a epic level you know you add
such a i don't know a magical intrigue
to the film i loved it so much talk
about working with keanu what what was
it like everybody loves him obviously
he's a national treasure what was your
experience like i see why okay he's um
he's a movie star but at the same time
he's the humblest nicest gentlest
person um and also very astute
you know extremely encouraging i was
nervous and
um when i first came in and i i remember
the end of the day
he came to me and he said when this
happened when i had all my lines and he
said to me and that was hard and you got
through it and you know really well done
and it's just so nice when
you've been through that through the day
and someone else acknowledges it and is
like great job you did a good job and it
was just something that i needed to hear
and i got really emotional about it and
it was very kind and that's what he's
like that's just who he is as a person
let me ask is your fam were you always
like you said you grew up on these films
where you and your family is your
current family as nick is he a fan i
imagine he is i can't imagine anybody's
not a fan but what's your family's take
on you being in there very excited i
think everyone in my family is very
excited i remember
my husband seen the movie so he
he loves it and um
i think just
for everyone whether it's my mom my
extended family my my husband you know
the excitement around being a part of
something that we all sort of grew up on
so yeah it's a it's an exciting time
leading up to the premiere what's
interesting always about the matrix for
me is that it kind of makes you question
reality life the everyday what we're
really doing and what maybe we should be
doing has the movie working on it and
and has it changed your perspective and
the way you look at the world i mean it
always makes you think that right like
what
is your react what is your matrix what
are you doing in your life to creating
to create your own matrix what what is
creating the impediments in your life
and what can you declutter to be able to
find your truth and i think that's what
the matrix really is about is to get to
the center of your truth and to
recognize what's real and what's not i
think that the the movie really makes
you think about
in depth who you are and where you want
to go
and what you're taking with you yeah
yeah well said what what if you could
pick out one thing what do you think it
is that that audiences latch on to the
most in the franchise there's so many
things to love i know that's a tough
question i know that's such a hard one
but i do think that at the center of the
matrix
beyond consciousness beyond reality and
beyond choice
i think it's love the basis of all of
these movies has been
love and peace and you know um
and everything that it takes to get
there and i think that's my favorite
part especially this one and i want to
take a minute to wish you a happy i
think three-year anniversary
congratulations um i'm married just
celebrating my tenure and i always like
to ask this to fellow married couples
what's your magic trick what's your what
do you think your secret to longevity is
i think just being honest and liking
each other's company honestly and you
know communication having fun with each
other
i think that's the most important the
key is to be able to enjoy each other's
company and just have a great time
then it just it doesn't feel like work
[Music]